non on ne peut pas soldat gay elle
défendit sa queen en omettant les
pardons moi je vais extrêmement choquant
ça comparé la plus sûre et rory très mal
à les déposséder franchement voilà ça
dessert complètement ça que je vois
c'est ce qu'on dit pas mal de gens et
c'est ça qui me fait de la peine parce
qu'elle a des services à côte d'argent
que l'on agit comme un aimant les
réseaux sociaux hier soir à chaque fois
que solveig parler c'est un véritable de
sketches parce que on a vu de nombreux
fous rires notamment avec benjamin
castaldi nicolas pernikoff et gayraud
genthod je vous avais où c'était assez
difficile de ne rien laisser paraître et
garder son calme quand elle me regarde
et limites en fait c'était un deux trois
soleil est en fait elle se retourner
comme ça il arrêtait de rigoler regarder
savez provocateur de 12 à 20 des
provocateurs de maladie c'est un peu
long pour les gens qui regardent faut
arrêter tous les jeunes intéressés par
les élections
non c'est vrai qu'on voit la croissance
des truites rencontre bombe à se
soutenir
on a eu un moment incroyable puisque
gilles verdez entre dans le game et là
je crois que c'est une des séquences et
plus majeurs de l'histoire de thé plp
regarde et à mesure que tu as regardé ça
chez toi tu rigoles là et regardez on a
tous rigolé quoi les camps de uma ont
été calquées sur l'élevage et millar
était tellement marché lecture que je
vais changer changer les abattoirs il
faut les changer
vidéo dans les abattoirs confrères ce
qui s'y passe
[Rires]
solvay ouais avec qu'à une meilleure
audition change vraiment la vie
[Applaudissements]
le plus c'est que solveig bois lll riez
très fort oui c'est vrai et on était
citrix était incontrôlable et nous on
enchaînait les fous rires voilà castaldi
je pouvais pas le regarder
c'était assez dur pour tout le monde de
garder son sérieux
regardez il faut abolir universellement
la seconde riz le règne de m possesseurs
six machines à produire de la viande
c'était pour selongey c'est cela a été
savamment je t'ai dis clairement manqué
alors je vous n'avez pas sûr que non et
due forme car si vous aussi vous plus
serré qu'en bellemare c'est pas ce soir
c'est un visio via ma maman maman tu
nous envoies cette guerre
[Rires]
et on a cru qu'une fois l'émission
terminée la rigolade était fini mais non
mais non parce que ces mythes va
toujours plus loin
ces 8 a fait une masterclass puisque
juste après d'avoir rendu l'antenne à
wizz la chaîne n'a rien trouvé de mieux
que d'enchaîner avec le partenaire le
partenaire de ces 8es regarder qui était
char alors que nerveux les masses
ouvrières regard qu'on va se fêter jeudi
reportage merci seul max merci baptiste
voilà et donc il dépensera l'adoma bien
entendu tout sera au point d'oublier pas
la télé j'étais là merci sauvé c'était
votre programme avec des mousses nous
rejoignent des déménagements d'exception
on dit chapeau les bretons alors c'est
qui la star du barbecue
c'était votre programme avec
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ja oui oui alors tel titre jossic ttp
nettoyeurs oui parce que en fait c'est
c'est pas un sujet sur lequel il faut ni
favori l on était plus on était tous
assez d'accord avec solberg
oui même le monsieur qui était là
qu'était et hop a dit voilà il ya 80%
des abattoirs des services le boulot et
voilà en fait le truc c'est que
aujourd'hui on est trop nombreux à dire
oui on aime les animaux mais on ne fait
rien et elle c'est son combat et je n'en
porte quelle personne si on est sur un
combat où il ya tellement d'injustices
où on voit des horreurs on a
l'impression qu'il ya le compte à
rebours est que personne ne fait rien
forcément on pète un plomb
sauf que c'est pas grave c'est une
spéciale sp6 team et même niveau les
êtres humains les insectes aux et moi je
suis désolé pardonne moi mais on peut
pas mettre au même niveau un déporté et
je suis sur le gâteau non parce que sur
plateau manoir inadmisible on peut faire
autrement à 5 81% mais c'est un bois
soit des bas mais je me dis qu'elle est
complètement j'ai regardé bord des
berges réglementer les abattoirs alors
il faut l'étourdissement à chaque soin
et il faut que les gens baissent et même
leurs moyens